so many families were being drowned
because they weren't given safe passage
and then who can forget that in
September 2015
an entire family of a man called Cordy
were drowned and that little boy was
found at Bodrum on the coast of Turkey
so I started fundraising and I think'll
all our awful lot of people started work
to try and help but I did a fundraiser
and turned then I thought no I've got to
go further afield than this arm so I've
spent the whole of this year really
going but I'm also in it I should
explain because when I was 2 was when
the war started and I remember the
refugees from London London refugees
they were called evacuees but streaming
out of London the government gave orders
that every family that had got
accommodation must open up their homes
to the refugees from London I've seen a
very different attitude throughout
Europe haven't we to to the migration
migration crisis there's been some
horrible instances and continues to be
an attitude that I find extremely
distasteful and quite frightening to be
honest I'm not frightened insofar as I'm
determined to protect I'm a citizen
that's been trained and brought up to
know human rights law and what frightens
me more than anything is that all our
governments included in the British
government are in contempt of human
rights law which we have signed and
ratified as a nation state now that is a
very bad situation